お～わいわい
おほほほ
こわい　こわい　こわい
やりましょうか
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと
弟です
はい、お帰りなさいませ～～
どうでしたか、留学は
え、でも、すごい楽しかったよ
オーストラリアっしょ？
うん
えかった？
えかった
うん
と、いうわけで
久しぶりに弟が遊びにきてるのですが
いや、今まさきがもうすぐくるんですんけれど
会いたいんだって
結構、仲良くさせてもらってたっしょ？
だから、久しぶりに顔を見たいって言ってて
今から、会いに来るんですけど
ま、そんな簡単に行かせませんよと
そう、一筋縄で俺のうちに入れると思ったら大間違いだ
と、いうわけで　今から
まさきが普通に入ってくるんですけど
ケンカしようや
兄弟の喧嘩って結構ガチだと思うんですよ
怖くない？　実際
他者が踏み込んで
いい
問題じゃない気がして
で、実際に喧嘩をおこしてみて
彼は
どうするのか
なかなか、兄弟でドッキリすることもないから
て、感じなんで
珍しく、兄弟で協力して
ドッキリをしていこうと思います
怒れる？
喧嘩できる？
いや、いけるよ
たぶん、いける
一回やってみるね
おい！
ふざけんなよ
ふざけんなって
や、でも笑ったら負けだかんね
この企画は
笑っちゃ負けなんで
ふざけんなよ
ホントごめん
おいら下いくから
おいらのカメラが壊されたっていう設定ね
下でお前さっき撮ってたっしょてことで
マジ撮れねえぞ動画
みたいな感じでいくから
お前の
ていう感じで、カメラだ壊れて
責任のなすりあいみたいな
きずいたら大喧嘩になってたみたいな
ではいこう
あ～もしもし
あ～おしさしぶりです～
さてと～
まさきデュエルしようぜ！
え、まじで俺
ディーヒールをなんで持ってこなかったんだろう
それやらかしてるね
なんか、はじめくんに
髪のばしといてって
言ってって言われた
え、これだって強いじゃん
最初はグー　ジョンケン
オネスト
先行で
ストライク　チェンジ
俺がチェンジ
投げ5かん
はははっは
よしよしよし
俺、めっちゃ
インフェニティー対策してたのに
インフェニティー対策してんの？
ちょっと下いってくるぽん
俺やっていいのか
いひひひひひひ
これ結構えぐいっすよ
それ強いよね
最初はグ　じゃんけん
はい、というわわけで
今、上でデュエルしてると思うんですけど
このカメラが壊れた設定で
突撃してやろうと思います
いくぜ
お前さっきさ～
カメラ落とさんかった？
ああ1回
下で？
うん
つかないんだけどこれ
結構こまるんですけどあした東京だから
明日東京？
明日東京
ガチやばすじゃん
いや、他のやつあるっしょ
や
一眼で撮りたかった
あしたはでも
やば、さっき落としたよね
まじ？
え、ほんまに動かんの？
うごかない
うん、さわりたくないわ
まじ？
なんか、落としたとかいったじゃん
カメラ系は割と
どうすんこれ
や、でも
なんとか、ならんの？
や、こっちじゃないとむりでしょ
普通のビデオカメラでもいいけど、画質が悪いから
どうする
や、俺に言われても
や、落としたのお前でしょ
下で
まあ
どうすんのこれマジで
うん
落としたんやけ
いうたら
や、持たしたはそうだけど、落とすなって言ったじゃん先に
や、それはおれ悪くない
いや、おまえだろ
ふざけんなよ
ブチきれたぞ
お前が落としたんだろこれ
なんで蹴ったの？
けるんはちゃうやろ
ふざけんなお前
ちょちょちょちょちょちょちょちょ
ふざけんなし
ちょちょちょちょちょ
ふざけんなよ
ちょちょちょちょ
下でお前が壊したんだよ、これ
いやいや、自分が重いんだよ
自分で管理しろって
ふざけんなよ
まってくださいって
ねえ～まってまって
すぐ、帰れよ今
ちょ～ちょちょ
ちょちょちょ
ストップ
ストップ　ストップ　ストップ
帰ってきたばっかだから
おまえ～
まって　まって　まって　まって
逃げんなよ
謝れとりあえず今！
あ！
お前が壊したんだろ
なんで俺なんねん
だからおまえ
自分のやん
落としたのお前じゃんでも
いやいや、自分のものぐらい自分で管理しろって
頭悪いんじゃないんかいお前
おい！にげんなよお前
もう帰るはさすがにムリ
バーカ
ばかって
あ～～～
おいデッキ
持って帰れよ
や、俺があげたんでしょ？
返せよ
いいよ　そんぐらい　いいよ
お前マジどうすんのこれ
帰るとかそういうことじゃなくて
まじ
注意したからってさ
いいわけじゃないじゃん
でもお前に
非はあるでしょ
少なくとも
じゃあ　謝れよ
すぐ今
まえに、蹴ったやん俺を
なんで蹴ったん意味わからないんだけど
暴力はちがくない、それは違うやん
そのあとお前もけったよな
やってること同じだよ
やったから蹴ったんやん
一応、お前に非はあるから
は？
てかもう帰っていい
無理なんだけど
なんなん
謝れとりあえず
それはちゃうわ
なんで
やられたやん
それは、始まるじゃんまた～
ていう
ドッキリです
ありがとうございます～～
も～なんなんも～～
はははっはははははっは
はははははははっは
ドッキリ大成功！！
弟がでるとちがうのかな～と
でしょ
こうゆうことよ
これが　　　家の日常
はははははははははは
苗字　苗字
ラーラ♭シドーラー
ド♭シラ♭シー
♭シド＃ドレー♭シー
レド♭シドーファーミレ
♭シラシミーソー
ファファ↑ミドラ
ファファファファ(END☆)